اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من تغطيتنا المتواصله للتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان وبينما تستمر
الاشتباكات لليوم الثالث اقر الجيش بدخول
قوات الدعم السريع الى مطار مروي العسكري
متعهدا باستعادته في اقرب وقت بينما اكد
الجيش ان جميع مقرات القياده العامه تحت
السيطره رغم الاشتباكات الضاريه التي تدور
منذ ساعات لكن في المقابل لا تزال قوات
الدعم السريع تؤكد سيطرتها على مقرات داخل
القياده العامه
وبهذا الاحداث التي
تحدث منذ الاول من امس هي محلات اشتباكات
ومحاولات اقتحامات بعدد من المقرات
العسكريه نحن نتصدى لهذه المحاولات
واضافه الى ان هنالك عمليات قنص واستهداف
لضباطنا وجنودنا لذلك تم جرت محاولات
لاعتقاد والقبض على
افرادنا ضباطنا وجنودنا اذا عرفوه الى
مواقعهم مواقع عملهم الرسميه تم
القبض على واقول اسف اما القبض على العديد
من الضباط الذين هم دارسون في
دورات او ضباط توجهوا الى الى مواقع عملهم
في الصباح تم اعتقالهم واعتبارهم بشريه في
مقرات ميديا
اشتباكات اليوم محدوده جدا اقل عده بكثير
من اليوم الاول من الامس نحن نعصر
عملياتنا في هذه المرحله في التصدي
لمحاولاتهم
القوات المسلحه في محيط القياده العامه
جميع مق
راتهم هي الان
نحن
سيطره
هذا وطلب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات نقلتها
وكاله من حسابه على تويتر طلب المجتمع
الدولي للتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد ما اسماه
بجرائم رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان
من جهه اخرى نشر الجيش السوداني بيانا
اتهام من خلاله قوات الدعم السريع بممارسه
اعمال سلب ونهب لممتلكات المواطنين بيان
الجيش اكد سيطرته على جميع مقرات القياده
العامه مشيرا الى عدم صحه سيطره الدعم
السريع على بيت الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري
او القياده العامه وقال البيانو ان القوات
الجويه للجيش تنفذ ضربات ضد عناصر الدعم
السريعي في الخرطوم
نؤكد انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه اساليب مضلله الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا المسلحه لاننا قوات محترفه
وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما بجميع
قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات نحن
نتقيد تماما بمقررات القانون الدولي
الانساني قانون الاذاعات المسلحه في هذا
النزاع المسلح
ورغم ان في الجيش كدا يوسف عزت مستشار
سياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس للسياده وقائد قوات
الدعم السريعه للعربيه صحته سيطره الدعم
السريعي على القصر الجمهوري وعلى مقرات
القياده العامه
نحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر
على كل
المتواجده على طول كل الوزارات نحن نسيطر
على كافه مداخل ولايه الخرطوم والكباري
كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه نحن
فقط عبر هذه القناه المواطنين ان هنالك
دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على مواطنين
او ينهب ممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه رخيصه نحن
نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل المواطنين
في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم من
المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها
الله اكبر يعني احنا
بنتصالحوا في السلطه
في النف للدوله
والشراب والتعليم والعلاج
استعاد الجيش السوداني سيطره على
التلفزيون وبالت بيانا وصف فيه قوه الدعم
السريع بالميليشيا ذكر الجيش السوداني في
بيانه ان قوه الدعم حاولت تدمير البنيه
التحتيه للتلفزيون بعد عجزهم عن السيطره
عليه وايداعه بيانهم
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
من التغطيه للاحداث في السودان اريد ان
ابدا معك بتصريحات الخارجيه
السودانيه ما ابرز ما تضمنته هذه
التصريحات
وكذلك نريد اجمالا كاملا لها سالم
نعم بدايه دعنا نتحدث عن ما يدور الان في
الارض
الان في الارض هناك اصوات لاعير ناريه
وتبادل اطلاق النار والمدافع كذلك في
اتجاه الخرطوم اتجاه القياده العامه وكذلك
هنا في منطقه بحري في منطقه كوبر ايضا
هناك
اصواتا تضج بها منطقه بحري قبل لحظات من
الان وما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه الخليه
السودانيه تقول انها تقدر جهود الوزاره
الافريقيه والعربيه والدوليه وانما يحدث
هو امر داخلي ينبغي ان يطلب للسودانيين
لانجاز التسويه فيما بينهم الخليه
السودانيه هنا تؤكد على عدم التدخل
الاخرين في الشونه السودانيه وان هذا
الامر سيتم
سيحله السودانيين فيما بينهم وسيصلون الى
تسويق في هذه القضيه الشائكه
وهذه الحرب الشائكه
ايضا لدينا العديد من الامور المتعلقه
بالشانه لانسان خاصه الشكاوي التي تاتينا
على راس كل دقيقه صحه العباره يعني
شكاوى من الاطباء من
اللجان كذلك لجان الاحياء عن عدم وجود طرق
وممرات امنه للوصول الى المصابين في
المستشفيات حتى الاطباء لا يستطيعون
الوصول الى مكان اعمالهم هناك ايضا
كبير من المصابين اذا كنت تسمع الان هذه
العير الناريه التي تنطلق هنا
لا يستطيعون الوصول الى
المستشفيات لان المستشفيات مليئه
بالمصابين
يعني طلب علي او ضغط عالي على المستشفى
يحتاج ان يصل اليه المسعفون والاطباء
فيواصلوا اعمالهم المستشفيات بعدها بالضبط
يعني يجلس المصابون في الطوارئ بعدم وجود
الكادر الطبي الذي يستطيع ان يقدم لهما
الرعايه هذه واحده حتى المعينات الطبيه
نفسها بدات تمثل في عديد من المستشفيات
هذه من الامور التي ايضا تتوارث الينا
تباعا على كل ويتصل علينا الاطباء وكذلك
المسؤولون في المستشفيات المختلفه في
العاصمه لانه يجب ان يكون هناك تدخل لوصول
هذه المساعدات حتى يستطيعوا ان ينشفوا
المصابين يعني قبل الحديث والعوده لموضوع
الاطباء الكوادر الطبيه الاشتباكات من
حولك سالم هل هي قريبه من سجن كوبر
الذي يتواجد فيه الرئيس المخلوع عمر
البشير
نعم هي الاشتباكات ليست في في
لا نعني بها في السجن وانما نعني في
الامتداد الذي يكون في الشارع الذي ينتهي
به كوبري كوبر هذا الطريق في هذه المنطقه
دائما او فيها في اليومين الماضيين حدثت
اشتباكات عنيفه في هذه المنطقه اريد ان
اذكر فقط بان منطقه كوبر بها يعني
عده مواقع عسكريه لمختلف الجهات مثلا في
كوبر يوجد ليس بعيد من هذه المنطقه جهاز
المخابرات العامه ليس بعيد من هذه المنطقه
ايضا احنا فرق الجيش السوداني كذلك
ويوجد السجن في هذه المنطقه كذلك فهي
منطقه فيها العديد من المقر العسكريه
الان في هذه الاثناء نستمع الى اصوات
للاشتباكات لكني لا ارى الان بعيني في في
اي منطقه بالضبط او لا استطيع التحديد في
هاي المنطقه من مناطق كوبر حتى الان اخيرا
في الوضع الانساني والاوضاع الطبيه
بالنسبه للمستشفيات هل هناك في الاساس نقص
في الكوادر الطبيه التي تعمل في
المستشفيات نحن لا نتحدث عن صعوبه الوصول
مستشفيات نتحدث عن نقص في الاساس موجود في
هذه المستشفيات
صحيح اضافه
المدافع الاسلحه الناريه تسبب القصف بخروج
المستشفى
الشعب تعليمي عن الخدمه وتقول ان قصف
المستشفيات يعد انتهاكا واضحا للقانون
الدولي حمايه المؤسسات
وتصحيح وتطالب المجتمع الدولي بانزام طرفي
الصراع بعدم المؤسسات الصحيه وفتح
الممرات الانسانيه يعني هناك مستشفيات
خرجت عن عن عن الخدمه سالم بعد ان تعرضت
للقصف او للرشقات ناريه
وما هي هذه المستشفيات
مستشفى الشعب هذا هو مستشفى الخرطومه
التعليم المستشفى
الاكبر على مستوى ولايه الخرطوم او على
مستوى الخرطوم بالضبط حتى نكون اكثر دقه
هو في هذه المنطقه التي ليس بعيد من القصر
الجمهوري وليس بعيد من القياده العامه
للجيش كذلك هذا المستشفى على شارع
مستشفى الشعب ومستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي
مستشفى كبير جدا مستشفى حكومي من اكبر
المستشفيات كما ذكرت لك في العاصمه
الخرطوم وهو في موقع سنتر اي في سنتر
الخرطوم في منتصف الخرطوم وسط الخرطوم
الان لجنه المركزيه تقول انه خرج عن
الخدمه اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي
اذا تشهد السودان وبالاخص العاصمه الخرطوم
اشتباكات مسلحه بين قوات الجيش بقياده
البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع بقياده حمى
التين وشاهد
اعمده دخان اشتباكات مسلحه رصاص ودماء
انها سله العرب الغذائيه التي ملئت قنابل
ومتفجرات بدل الطعام والشراب
الله اكبر
نحو سته عشر انقلابا عسكريا ومحاوله
انقلاب منذ استقلاله بعثرت خيراته واهدرت
مقدراته انه السودان
نحو 46 مليون مواطن نصفهم فقراء في بلد
فيه اكثر من عشره انهار طبيعيه ومئه وخمسه
وسبعين مليون فدان من الاراضي الصالحه
للزراعه في السودان ما يزيد عن 100 مليون
راس من الماشيه اي اضعاف ما تملكه هولندا
هنا تاسع بلد منتج للذهب على مستوى العالم
وثالث بلد منتج للنفط على مستوى افريقيا
وفيما تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تعالت الاصوات شعبيا مطالبه بوقفها
على الفور والوصول الى حلول تلبي طموح
المدنيين بسودان مختلف
اظهرت صور اضرام النار في مدرج مطار
الخرطوم جراء الاشتباكات المستمره بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
العربيه نقلا عن مصادر محليه وشهود عيان
بمدينه نيالا بولايه جنوبي دارفور غرب
السودان باستمرار الاشتباكات المسلحه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في عدد من احياء
المدينه فيما تؤكد قيادات عسكريه ان
قواتها تتمركز امام مقر قياده الجيش في
نيالا والمقر الاستراتيجيه في المدينه
بينها البنوك التجاريه والمؤسسات الرسميه
وبالتزامن ايضا نقل شهود عيان عن وقوع
عمليات سلب ونهبل في عدد من مقر المنظمات
الدوليه والمحليه بالمدينه
وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي خلال لقائه نظريه
البريطاني جيمس او نظيره البريطاني جيمس
كليفرلي قال ان بلاده تشعر بقلق عميق تجاه
استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان مؤكدا على
اهميه الاتفاق مع الحلفاء على ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات الدائره بلينكن اضاف ايضا ان
الشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
لثكناتهم حيث يتطلعون الى دوله ديمقراطيه
من جهه وزير الخارجيه البريطاني الطرفي
الصراع الى اعطاء الاولويه للسلام لانهاء
الى اسمح
قلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في السودان
والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين وعلى
السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق تجاه
استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا هنا
في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء في
الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق مشترك
حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على ضمان
حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفي النزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للسكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
وفي هذه الاثناء حتى المبعوث الاممي
للسودان فولكر بريتس جميع الاطراف على
احترام التزاماتها الدوليه بما في ذلك
ضمان حمايه جميع المدنيين وقال بيريتس ان
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لم
يلتزم امس بوقف القتال الذي اعلن عنه
لاغراض انسانيه الا بشكل جزئي مشيرا الى
خيبه امل شديده جراء تجدد الاشتباكات
اذا يوم ثالث من الاشتباكات لا ينبئ بان
السودان سيعود ادراج المربع الاول من
الحوارات ومع احتدام المعارك تبرز
سيناريوهات الموقف الراهن في السودان اولا
ورغم ضبابيه الصوره فان سيناريو الحرب
الاهليه ما يزال مستبعدا فالجيش حتى
المدنيين على عدم الانخراط في المعارك
الجاريه والسبب انها معركه سلطه في المقام
الاول اما سيناريو عدم الحسم فانه وارد
ايضا مع تصعيد الدعم السريع هجومه ليلا
بالمدفعيه لكن ميزان القوه لقوات الجيش
سيمكنها في النهايه من الحسم ان لم يتطور
الموقف الى حرب شوارع في العاصمه
السيناريو الثالث يرجح ان امد الحرب لن
يطول كثيرا اي انها معركه محدوده زمنيه
ويدعم هذا المؤشر الانشقاقات من جانب
المنتدبين في الدعم السريع بالاضافه الى
الانشقاق قياديه اما السيناريو الرابع فهو
الرهان على الوساطه الخارجيه وهو القاسم
المشترك بين الطرفين لكنه هجوم الدعم
السريع ليلا يشيء بانهم يحاولون الحسم قبل
بدء الوساطه في حين يؤكد الجيش انه لن
يرضى بالوساطه قبل ردع الدعم السريع
وننتهي مع السيناريو الاخير والذي يرجح ان
تعود قوات الدعم السريع الى دارفور مجددا
والتحرك من هناك كقوه انفصاليه يصعب نزع
شوكتها
ومعنى من القاهره استاذ العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور طارق فهمي دكتور طارق مرحبا بك
معي في هذه التغطيه اكثر من سيناريو لهذه
الازمه لمجريات هذه الازمه برايك دكتور اي
السيناريوهات اقرب
يعني من خلال
تشاهده الان وفق الموقف الحالي لطرفي هذه
الازمه
هو بالتاكيد ده يعني سيناريو عدم الحسم هو
الاكثر يعني طرحا وترجيحا هناك وزن نسبي
كما تعلم حضرتك لكل السيناريو مطروح من
حضرتك اشرت واتكرمت به لكن ربما يكون
السيناريو عدم الحسم لجمله من الاسباب جزء
منها متعلق
بهدف كل طرفه الطرفين يسعوا بطبيعه الحال
هناك سعي لامتداد العمليات تدفع كل طرف
لطرف الاخر عدم وجود تجاوب مع المبادراتا
التي طرحت خلال الساعات الاخيره تصميم كل
طرف على تحسين شروط التفاوض لاحقا حينما
يحين وقت التفاوض وبالتالي العمل العسكري
يستبق اي عمل سياسي في هذا التوقيت
وبالتالي اعتقد عدم الحسم ايضا نتيجه
لانفتاح المشهد على السيناريوهات عديده
نستطيع ان نجمع العديد من السيناريوهات
بجوار هذه السيناريوهات النظريه لكن
واقعيا الامر يختلف تماما العمل العسكري
هو من سيحسم الطرفين لكن ربما يكون
والاخير لحضرتك اشرت اليه هو انحصار يعني
الدعم السريع وعودته الى مناطق تمثل
استراتيجيه في دارفور وتحوله الى حركه
يعني حركه مسلحه او حركه متمرده لانه
تاريخ السودان هناك حركات عسكريه حتى الان
تحمل حضرتك السلاح ورفضت الانضواء في
القوات المسلحه برغم ان بعض الحركات دخلت
بعض الفرقه الخاصه وبالتالي عنصر بقاء
التدخل السريع والحسب السريع في المواجهه
هذا امر وارد سيحسموا امور عسكريه بمعنى
اذا طالت امد المواجهه وهو ايضا متوقع
سيكون هناك مدخلات حتى الان هناك في
مدخلات محيده بعد تقريبا ثلاث ايام من
العمليات في كل طرف سيستقوي به اوراقه
وبالاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه في انتظار
قدره الحسم بمعنى انه الطرفين حتى الان لم
يبدي اي تجاوب مع اي مبا سلميه مطروحه
وستشهد خلال الساعات المقبله مبادرات اخرى
يعني لن تتوقف عن ايجاد او المفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي او حتى الرباعيه الدوليه
واعتقد والجامعه العربيه كل هذه الامور
ستتداخل بطبيعه الحال سيكون هناك تداخل
الموقف المباشر ستحسمه القوه العسكريه وفي
تقدير لازلنا نحن في المربع رقم واحد من
كل ما تشاهده الان لانه بطبيعه الحال لو
بتحلل تحليل مضمون له بيانات كل طرف بصرف
النظر عن صدقيتها او عدم سقيتها او
مصداقيه ما يتم طرحهم نقف امام عده امور
ان شعرت معاويه قطعت ما بين الطرفين
وبالتالي حديث بيانات القوات المسلحه
الرسميه حتى هذه اللحظه تحدثت في الاول
على انها ميليشيات ومتمرده ثم
عادت خلال الساعات الاخيره فدعت الى
الدعم السريع بتسليم سلاحهم والانضمام الى
اشقائهم في القوات المسلحه وعوده الذين
كانوا انتدبوا هذا معناه اننا امام القوات
المسلحه خيارات متعدده واعتقد انه العمل
العسكري سيستمر لبعض الوقت تفضل دكتور
طارق تقول قطعت شعره معاويه ربما يعني
تتحدث هنا عن
الحوار عن يعني التهدئه جلوس الطرفين على
يعني طاوله مستديره لكن الخارجيه
السودانيه
ربما تؤكد هذا الكلام بقولها بان الوضع
الراهن شان داخلي والسودانيون سيتوصلون
الى التسويه بانفسهم ما الذي يعنيه هذا
التصريح الدكتور طارق هل يعني سد الباب
امام كل الوساطات الخارجيه للتدخل بين
طرفي الازمه
بالتاكيد حضرتك سالته واجبت طبعا هذا هو
المطروح حتى المندوب
السوداني امس في الجامعه العربيه ذكر هذا
وبيان الخارجيه كما اشرت حضرتك هذا معناه
انه لابد ان يكون هناك حل من داخل السودان
وفق لي المقاربه الخاصه بالخارجيه
السودانيه هذا الامر ربما سيدفع بعض القوى
السياسيه الداخليه في السودان للتحرك حتى
هذه اللحظه المعلومات التي تصلنا هي
مرتبطه بالحركات المسلحه حتى ان بعضها لم
ينضم كما اشرت الى
الجيش السوداني وتدخل في عمليه او التكامل
الذي طرح في وقتها حتى الحل السياسي
الداخلي اللافت للنظر هو
تجمع الحركات المسلحه المتمرده التي وصفت
في مراحل معينه انها متمرده وبالتالي
اليوم هل سيكون الحل السياسي من خلال هذه
الحركات الامر الاخر هو المكون السياسي
المكون السياسي ليس على قلب رجل واحد هناك
صراعات عديده راسيه وافقيه وهناك تباين في
الرؤى وهناك ايضا تحفظات على ما كان يعرف
بالاطار اتفاقيه الاطار اليوم نتكلم على
سياسه الامر الواقع سقط فعليا ما يعرف
بالاتفاق الاطار لانه اذا جلس الطرفين
الان في هذا التوقيت اللي بكلم حضرتك فيه
وتم وقف اطلاق النار سيتم وضع القوات على
على مناطق ومراكز ومسارح العمليات فربما
يكون هناك رابح وربما يكون هناك خاسر يعني
ستبقى الاوضاع على ما هي عليه هل سترضى
القوات المسلحه السودانيه ان تبقى قوات
الدعم السريع في مناطق تمركزها بما يمثل
لها خطرا ام انها ستتبع استراتيجيه اخرى
متعلقه بالتقسيم او التقسيم المناطقي وهذا
امر وارد حضرتك في ظل ما نشهده من تعقد
المشهد العسكري بمعنى ان كل طرف ليست
لديهم مناطق تمركز خاصه به الان نتحدث عن
قوات
متشابكه ومتفاعله فاذا تم وقف اطلاق النار
ستكون هناك اشكاليه في فصل هذه القوات من
يقوم بها من سيعطي الضمانات من سينفذ
اجراءات بناء الثقه في جمله من
التساؤلات والاشكاليات المطروحه حتى مع
التجاوب التفاؤل يعني هذا السيناريو
التفاؤل تفاؤل اذا تم وقف اطلاق النار
وبدانا الحديث عن عمليه سياسيه اشكرك جزيل
الشكر على المشاركه معي من القاهره الساده
العلوم السياسيه الدكتور طارق فهمي
ادانت نقابه اطباء السودان صراع السلطه في
البلاد بين طرفين نزاع مع خروج مستشفيات
الشعب التعليمي والخرطوم التعليمي عن
الخدمه تماما وقالت اللجنه في بيانها ان
قصف المرافق الصحيه يعد انتهاكا واضحا
للقانون الدولي الانساني والمواثيق التي
تنص على حمايه المؤسسات الصحيه وتحيدها من
الاستهداف كما والحق القصف اضرارا بالغه
بعده مراكز طبيه كمستشفى بشاير وابن سيناء
التخصصي
النزاع الحالي مشاهدين بين الجيش بقياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقوات الدعم السريع
بقياده محمد حمدان دقلو انهى علاقه تعاون
وتحالف قديما استمرت لسنوات بين الرجلين
امتدت لاكثر من عقدين من الزمن فكيف تطورت
هذه العلاقه قبل ان تنقلب الى عداوه
السودان يسقط في وحل الاقتتال بين اقوى
الرجلين عسكريين في البلاد فانقطاع حبل
الود بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدانو
اوقع السودان في المحظور اتهامات وتوعد
وتهديد بالقتل هكذا تحول الخطاب بين
الرجلين الذين نسفا في لحظات علاقه تحالف
وعمل مشترك دامت نحو 20 عاما الرجلان عمل
سويا لاول مره سنه 2003 حين اتحدا للتصدي
لجماعات مسلحه في اقليم دارفور دجالو
الملقب بحميتي انشا حينها مجموعه صغيره
مسلحه ووضع يده في يد البرهان الذي كان
حينها منسقا لعمليات الجيش في دارفور ومنذ
ذلك الحين والرجلان يصعدان المراتب بشكل
تدريجي عاد ليتصدر المشهد سنه 2019 حين
اتحدا من جديد وهذه المره ليس الا لاسقاط
عمر البشير الذي قاتلا تحت رايته سويا قبل
16 عاما
هدف مشترك جمعهما ليبرما تحالفا
استراتيجيا لكن انهاء مهام الحكومه
المدنيه وسيطره البرهان الى جانب حميتي
على الحكم خليفه سنه 2021 حمل معه اولى
شذرات الخلاف الحقيقيه فالبرهان اعاد بعد
عناصر نظام البشير الى السلطه وهو ما
اعترض عليه حميتي لكن نقطه التي افادت
الكاس تمخضت عن الاتفاق الاطاري الذي حمل
بين ثناياه مقترح اصلاح النظام العسكري
ودمج قوات الدعم السريع مقترح كان مجرد
قنبله موقوته انفجرت لتنهي تحالفا
استراتيجيا وتشعل عداوه قد تحرق نيرانها
البلاد وسمى الذهبي العربيه
[تصفيق]
ومن مدينه مروي انضموا الينا مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه قبل قليل ذكرت بان الحركه لا
تزال ضئيله فيما روي حتى الان هادئه نوعا
ما السكان يلتزمون منازلهم خوفا من
الاشتباكات هل لا تزال ذات الصوره في مروي
المشهد
ذات الامني الذي فرض على سكان هذه المدينه
مدينه مروي قبل قليل كنا قد ارسلنا عادل
بان اشتباكات بدات تدور راحاها داخل مطار
مروي الدولي والقاعده العسكريه الجويه
العمليه الملحقه بهذا المطار شاهدنا اعمده
والسنه الدخان تتصاعد
لاحظنا ايضا بالعين
فوهات البنادق والمدافع تنطلق منها
القاذفات صوب عمق المطار وعمق القاعده فسر
وفق عسكريين بانه اشتباك من قبل الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه ضد قوات الدعم
السريع التي تتمركز في الداخل بحسب ايضا
تاكيدات الجيش السوداني لقناه العربيه ااا
السنه الدخان انخفضت قليلا الان هنالك
حاله من الهدوء والصمت يطبق على
حواش واطراف القاعده وعمق القاعده لم نعد
نستمع الى
كان هنالك ذوي لم نتاكد هل هو دوي لطائرات
حربيه عسكريه مقاتله ام هو ام هو الدوي
لسيارات او
للقاذفات او للمدفعيه الثقيله من داخل
المطار لكن الوضع الان داخل مدينه مروي هو
هادئ يسيطر عليه التوتر والترقم من قبل
المواطنين الاجواء فيها كثير من
الترقب لما سيحدث خلال الساعات او الدقائق
المقبله كل الارضيه المتعلقه بمساحه وتمدد
العمليه العسكريه هي فقط داخل محيط المطار
والقاعده ولم تمتد حتى الان نحو المدينه
اي ان المدينه السالمه وامنه ولم تدخل بعض
في دائره الصراع الدائره الان بقاعده مروي
او بالمطار العسكري هل شاهدتم او رصدتم
طائرات تحلق فوق مطار مراوي فوق القاعده
ايضا كذلك نزار
استمعنا الى اصوات اصوات عزيز او ذوي لكن
لم نلمح بالعين المجرده او لم نشاهد
الطائره لكن طبيعه الانفجارات التي حدثت
في القاعده وفي المطار تحتاج ايضا الى
تفسير هل الطريقه التي انفجرت بها الاليات
او المواقع التي ضربتها هل ضربت عبر اليات
ثقيله عبر مدفعيه ثقيله ام ضربت عبر
الطيران هذا يحتاج ايضا الى تفسير والى
معلومات جهاد عسكريه تؤكد هل الضرب الذي
تم قبل قليل كان عبر سلاح الطيران
السوداني ام عبر المدفعيه الثقيله ربما
المعلومات تفيد وتؤكد وتدلل خلال الساعات
المقبله ايضا الناطق اسم الجيش السوداني
كان قد تحدث للعربيه بان استعاده مطر مروي
ستكون في اقرب وقت يعني او في وقت وجيز
يعني
هل هناك ما ينبئ بان الجيش السوداني يتحرك
الاتجاه من خلال العمليات حول المطار
نعم يبدو ذلك من شواهد هذه الاجتهادات
وهذه العمليه
ايضا وفق المعلومات الاوليه بانه يحاول ان
يبدا هذا المسار مساره الاستيعاب لهذه
القاعده التي كان قد سيطر عليها امس
وخرجت الدعم السريع منها ولكن تغيرت
معطيات الميدان العسكري وعادت القوات الى
الداخل قوات الدعم السريع بوفق ايضا
المتحدث باسم الجيش والان يبدو انه يحاول
ان يستعيد ذات المسار الذي سلكه يوم الامس
بقبضته وبسيطرته وببسط نفوذه على ارضيه
هذا المطار والقاعده العسكريه تقول تغيرت
المعطيات كيف نزار
يوم الامس خرجت قوات
الدعم الجيش قال بانه حسب المعلومات ايضا
التي تحصلنا عليها بانه يطبق المسارات
والاتجاهات في هذه القاعده لكن حسب ايضا
تصريحات المتحدث باسم الجيش في قناه
العربيه اثقل قبل ساعه من الان بان قوات
الدعم السريع هي فعلا متمركزه وانهم يسعون
وتعهدوا بان تتواصل العمليه العسكريه الى
ان يتم استعادت هذه القاعده
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل سنتابع معك خلال هذه النشره
ونشرتنا القادمه الجده جديد معك من مروي
نزار البغداوي مراسل العربيه
خلوها قبضنا
ماشي حيه ماشيه حيه ملل
زي ما قاعد تقولوا اسرع ربطكم في فتيلنا
ها كويس الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
عربات الدعم السريع في قبضه القوات
المسلحه بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله
لئيمه الرساله لاي ميليشيا
خلوها قبضنا
ماشيه حيه ماشيه حيه فلل
زي ما قاعد تقولوا عرباتكم في فتيلنا ها
كويس الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
عربات الدعم السريع في قبضه القوات
المسلحه بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله
لايجه رساله لاي ميليشيا
استعاد الجيش السوداني السيطره على
التلفزيون وبث بيانا وصففيه قوات الدعم
السريع بالميليشيا وذكر الجيش او ذكر
الجيش السوداني في بعينه ان قوات الدعم
حاولت تدمير البنيه التحتيه للتلفزيون بعد
عجزهم عن السيطره عليه واذاعه بيانهم
نحن النعام عظيم بنطلق النخيل تمساح
[موسيقى]
السوداني الذي عاود
البث مره اخرى ووصف قوات الدعم السريع
بالميليشيات المتمرده اذا وفي ذات الموضوع
اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع حصيله
ضحايا الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الى 97 قتيلا ووفق البيان فان عدد
القتلى يتجاوز هذه الحصيله منذ اندلاع
الاشتباكات لاسيما وان الكثيره منهم لم
ينقلوا الى المستشفيات اما بسبب وضع حرج
او صعوبه في التنقل
[موسيقى]
الطالب وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه خلال
مؤتمر الصحفيين جمعه بنظيره الامريكي
على هامش اجتماع السبعي في اليابان طلب
بوقف فوري للعنف الدائري في السودان
والعوده الى حوار يفطي الى حكومه مدنيه
مؤكدا ان بلاده ستستمر بالعمل مع
الامريكيين ودول افريقيه وعربيه للوصول
الى حل في السودان
في وقت سابق اليوم اجرينا نقاشا حول الوضع
في السودان وقد تواصلنا مع اصدقائنا في
المنطقه العربيه
وسنستمر بالتواصل وفي نفس الوقت ايضا اود
التاكيد اننا نتفق مع ما قاله الوزير
بلنكن في الدعوه لوقف فوري للعنف والعوده
لمفاوضات تسير باتجاه انتاج حكومه مدنيه
وهذا بالتاكيد هدفنا الاكبر وكلانا سنستمر
بالعمل مع الولايات المتحده واصدقائنا في
افريقيا وفي العالم العربي للوصول الى
السلام والى ديمقراطيه مدنيه
هذا ودع وزير وخارجيه بريطانيا جنرالات
السودان المنخرطين في المعارك الى جعل
السلام اولويه والعوده الى الحوار
واخيرا ادعو الجنرالات السودانيين
المنخرطين في هذه المعارك لوضع السلام
اولا و لوضع حد للقتال والعوده الى
المفاوضات هذا ما يريده الشعب السوداني
وهذا ما يستحقه السودانيون ونحن سنستمر
بالبحث عن سبل لدعم طريق العوده للسلام
صرح المتحدث باسم الامين العام لجامعه
الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط انه اجر
اتصالا هاتفيا مع عبد الله حمدوك رئيس
وزراء السودان السابق حيث اوضح جمال رشدي
المتحدث الرسمي ان ابو الغيط عبر لحمده عن
اقتناعه بان الخروج من الازمه الخطيره
التي تمر بها البلاد يتطلب من كافه مكونات
الطيف السياسي التكاتف والعمل معا اضاف
المتحدث ان ابو الغيط حرص على الاستماع
لرؤيه حمدوك لتطورات الاوضاع واتفق معه في
اولويه وقف التصعيد والوقف الفوري
للاشتباكات المسلحه اوضح المتحدث ان ابو
الغيط يجري في الاونه الاخيره عددا من
الاتصالات عاليه المستوى بحثا عن سبل لوقف
التصعيد العسكري الحالي والاستعاده الحوار
بين الاطراف في السودان
العسكر للسكنات والاحزاب للانتخابات
دايرين الانتخابات حره فيها
[تصفيق]
من الناحيه الاخرى ومع التحريك المكثفه
للطائرات الحربيه للجيش يبدو ان السيطره
على القواعد العسكريه الجويه الشغل الشاغل
الان لدى قوات الدعم السريع فسلاح الجو
وفق عسكريين النقطه الفاصله في المعركه
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فمن
يحكموا السيطره عليها يحسم المعركه نتابع
معركه السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه قوات
الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه تعلم
ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه فكانت
البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حمادتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مروي الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده مروي لاحتوائها على
اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم مركز
فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار وتليها
اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخ الطائرات
وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء السالم
العربيه
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الرشيد المعتصم
محمد الباحث في مركز الخرطوم للحوار سيد
الرشيد اهلا ومرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
الى اين تتجه الامور حتى هذه اللحظه
بتقديرك وبقراءتك ايضا
نهارك سعيد واضح جدا انه ما زالت هناك
مناوشات
وعمليات انتحاريه تقوم بها قوات الدعم
السريع في داخل الخرطوم وفي منطقه مروي
قدره هذه القوات نفس هذه القوات ليس طويلا
ادركها على احتلال المواقع والمدن واضح
انه ضعيف
الاعتبارات عند ابرزها يعني خطوط امداد لا
توجد لها خطوط امداد
عندما يتم ايضا
باعتبارنا عمليات احنا نفسها لا تقوم على
هذه الفرديه ولكنها عمليات تقوم على فرديه
عمل اعلامي واسع يدعم يدعم فكره الحوار
التي التي يروج لها بعض
التروج لها بعض الدول وبعض الوساطات في
دول الاقليم الافريقي والعربي والعالم
الخارجي
لكن نفسها قصير
ليس لها خطوط امداد
عقيدتها القتاليه تختلف عن العقيده
القتاليه القوات المسلحه عندها مشروع واضح
ليس لديها مشروع واضح المعالم يعني تقاتل
لاجل قادم متمردين يعني فهذا ايضا يضعف من
عقيدتها العسكريه ثانيا لا يستطيعون
البقاء لفترات طويله
وعندما يتم الضغط عليهم يسحبون بلا عتاد
ولا ولا خلا يطلقون اعدادهم الحر ويتركون
متحركاتهم فالجيش اقلب متحركات وسلاح
الدعم السريع في الميدان وفي المخازن يعني
جزء كبير منه الان تحت سيطره
لكن وحسبه تصريحات يعني احد قاده الدعم
السريع للعربيه في نشره سابقه يقول بان
هذه المعركه اقتربت من النهايه وبان
البرهان وصفه
بالهرب بانه هرب من من الخرطوم حسب حديثه
وبانهم سيطروا
القصر الجمهوريه سيطروا كذلك على مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه سيطروا على
قاعده مروي وبالتالي الامور الميدانيه
يعني ان صحت هذه الانباء وهذه الاخبار
وهذه المعلومات التي نقلها فيبدو ان الدعم
القوات الدعم السريع تتجه يعني الى كسب
اكبر في هذه المعركه حتى الان سيد الرشيد
واضح
ان الخطه التي اعتمد عليها ابداع غاده
الدعوه السريع من البدايه تقوم على على
العمليات السريعه والاسناد الاعلام
الالكتروني ولكن يعني
الموجودون هنا في الخرطوم من كافه اطياف
يعني
السودانيون دون تفصيلا في اطراف الخرطوم
وفي قراها وفي الشريط المحاذي للولايات
المجاوره الان يوثقون لهروب هذه القوات
ولتحركاتها ويرسلونها يعني في التعاطف
كبير مع الجيش يعني هذه القوات الان ممكن
ان تطلق عليها قوات بلا قياده مركزيه هذه
القوات تقاتل تقديرات القاده الميدانيين
يعني هم يعني بعضهم قد لا يعرف الجغرافيا
السياسيه للمنطقه وبعضهم لا تعوزوا الخبره
حتى العسكريه يعني يتحركون وفقا ويذبح خطط
المركزيه والان ما فيش سيطره مركزيه يعني
هم بيقدرون لذلك يعتدون على المنازل
والمواطنين ويكسرون الاسواق للحصول على
على التموين وبالمقابل للجيش
السوداني هل يعني تريد ان توصل فكره ان
استراتيجيه الجيش القوات المسلحه
استراتيجيه
استراتيجيه نفس طويل ممكن ان تنجح في
السيطره وضبط الاوضاع في العاصمه الخرطوم
وباقي الولايات
خطا باعتبار ان الجيش لا يمكن ان يدخل في
عمل حربي داخل
الاحياء والمزارع بشكل بشكل حربي كامل
ولكنه اذا انا اتوقع عندما يتم تحديد
القوات والارسكريه المتحركات
يعني بشكل كبير غد المرحله اللاحقه قد
ربما تبدا قدم او بعد قدم تكون هي تمشيط
المدن وهذه عاده لا يقوم بها الجيش وحده
لكن تقوم تقوم معه يعني قوات خاصه مسانده
تدخل ايضا مواطن من الشرطه خاصه اسمها
قوات الاحتياطي المركزي ايضا تنجح في مثل
هذه هذه المهام
وتساعد الاجهزه الامنيه والمواطنين
بالمعلومات يعني فانا اتوقع انفتاح بعد
لانهاء هذه بعد نهايه هذه المناوشات
والقضاء على المتحركات الهائمه قد تبدا
مرحله لاحقه هي التمشيط داخل الاحياء وهذه
تقوم بها قوات مشتركه يعني من التجارب
السابقه طيب ابقى معي سيدي رشيد
هل هناك كما تريد ان تضيفه قبل ان انتقل
الى الخبر القادم
يعني
في محيط القياده العامه اسمع اطلاق اصوات
رصاص يبدو ان هناك مجموعات ايضا متحركه
في اتجاه القياده العامه هم دائما
يستهدفونه مواقع سياديه ومواقع رئيسيه
القياده العامه بالنسبه لهم هدفها ايضا
حتى مراسل العربيه ينقل في هذا الخبر
العاجل بان هناك قصف عنيف واشتباكات بمحيط
مقر القياده العملي الجيش في الخرطوم كما
ذكرت سيدي الرشيد ابقى معي ساعود
اليك نبقى في ذات
ملف مشاهدينا حيث تتواصلوا الاشتباكات في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش بالعاصمه
الخرطوم ويقع مقر القياده العامه في
المنطقه الشماليه من العاصمه على بعد على
بعد نحو اربعه كيلو مترات فقط من مطار
الخرطوم كما يتواجد بالقرب من مقر قياده
القوات البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات
الجويه ويعد مقر القياده العامه مركزا
مهما وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني
ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى تداول
اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
مطار مروي العسكري كان محل تضارب هو الاخر
بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع فقد
اعلن الجيش السوداني السيطره على مطار
مروي العسكري وعلى قياده قطاع كردفان وكان
مراسل العربيه قد افاد في وقت سابق ان
الجيش السوداني انتشر في محيط قاعده مروي
شمال السودان بعد انسحاب قوات الدعم
السريع حيث نشر عناصر من الجيش السوداني
مقطع فيديو يوثق دخولهم قاعده مروي
العسكريه
انا في مطار
مروه الدولي
القاعده الجويه
الله اكبر ولله الحمدانيه
في المقابل وقبل ذلك اعلنت قوات الدعم
السريع احكام سيطرتها هي الاخرى على مطار
مروي نحن الان الشعب السوداني
بشكل كامل والحمد لله اخواننا في القوي
المسلحه
الشعب
مع انتشار المواجهات المسلحه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في عده محاور من
الخرطوم دعونا نتعرف على الطبيعه
الجغرافيه الى العاصمه السودانيه التي
تتجه اليها الانظار
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين ثمانيه الى عشره
ملايين نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون
اليها يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه
الاكبر من السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم
وام درمان الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا
متداخله في المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل
بين الجيش وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال
حدوث ما لا تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال
سيكون امام قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد
للنزوح وهو الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن
الواقعه على النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما
يتعلق بسكان الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك
شمالا او شرقا للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال
اخيرا سينبغي على سكان ام درمان انه
الاوضاع الامنيه امنهم النزوح الى المدن
الواقعه غرب وشمال وجنوب ام درمان
اصدرت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه بيانا
اوضحت فيه ان البرهان اصدر قرارا بحل
الدعم السريع واعلانها قوه متمرده على
الدوله وسيتم التعامل معها على هذا الاساس
كما اكدت الخارجيه ان كل الوساطات الوطنيه
لدمج الدعم السريع بالجيش قد باءت بالفشل
جاء في البيان ايضا ان القوات المسلحه
تعتمد استراتيجيه قتاليه لتقليل الخسائر
ان الوضع الراهن شان داخلي وسودانيون
سيتوصلون الى التسويه بانفسهم
عود مره اخرى الى السيد الرشيد المعتصم
الباحث في مركز الخرطوم للحوار سيد اب
الرشيد يعني قبل قليل الخارجيه السودانيه
تقول بان السودانيين سينهون هذه المساله
وهذه الخلافات بانفسهم هل هذه اشاره
مباشره يعني عدم نيتهم الدخول في اي حوار
في اي وساطات ايضا من اطراف دوليه او حتى
اقليميه
الجيش السوداني لن يدخل في حوار السبب
الاول انه في الميدان هو المنتصر السبب
الثاني ان السودانيون نفسهم لا يقبلون ان
تنتهي هذه المعركه
ويكون هناك جيشان لانه اصلا هذه الازمه
ازمه تطاولت
الجيش تعامل معها برفق
والدعم السريع عجل بهذه المعركه يعني
المؤجله فهذه المعركه اصلا في غرفه
السودانيين يعني ازمه السودان في الفتره
الاخيره غير
الضعف بتاع الاحزاب السياسيه هي وجود
جيشين يعني وخروج الدعم السريع عن طوى
القوات المسلحه يشكل تحديد
والسودانيه الان حتى الجيش لا يمكن قاده
وضباط
قيادات الوسيطه وافراد الجيش والمواطنين
السوداني الان لا يقولون بوضع سيد الرشيد
من يقول بان يعني هذه القوه قوات الدعم
السريع كانت تحت عباءه الجيش كانت منضويه
او تاتم بامر القوات قائد القوات المسلحه
لكن البرهان هو من اصدر القرار
بخروجها من عباءه الجيش وباستقلالها بشكل
كامل في 2019 الا يتحمل هنا جزءا من هذه
المساله
وقد يتحمل اطراف كثيره تتحمل المسؤوليه
النظام السابق البرهان غيره لكن نحن الان
معنيين بالمرحله ما معنيين بما سبق هذه
تقديرات سياسيه
وعسكريه
لاشخاص لانظمه لكن احنا معنيين باللحظه
الان يعني في هذه اللحظه
يعني
يعني وجود جيشين هذا يعني غير مرغوب فيه
لابد من توحيد القوات المقاتله لابد من
صوت واحد ووجود جيش يعني يتحدث
ويطلعنا حربيه ويتوسع جغرافيا ويبني اموال
بعضها مشبوه وبعضها مشروع وغير مرئي
ويخلق شبكه مصالح هذه في القران المدني
ايوه لكن في
القطاع يكون مهدد
ليس
للاستقرار السودان ولكن للاقليم نفسه
باعتبار ان وجود هذه الوضعيه سيساهم في
وجود جيوش اخرى في السودان السودان بلد
واسع واضح السيد الرشيده نشكرك جزيل الشكر
لم يتبقى لديه الكثير من الوقت من الخرطوم
الرشيد المعتصم الباحث المركز الخرطوم
للحوار شكرا جزيلا لك
شكلت الازمه الرهينه في السودان ضربه
جديده لاقتصاد البلاد واستمرار صراع
العسكري قد يجعل من الصعب خروج السودان من
الازمه الاقتصاديه الضاربه بجذورها لعقود
مضت
لا يمكن رسم صوره متفائله للاقتصاد
السوداني في ظل التصعيد المسلح بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل هذه
الاشتباكات كان الاقتصاد يرزح تحت سلسله
من الازمات التي يعود تاريخها الى حقبه
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير واستمرت حتى بعد
سقوطه في 2019
الحكومه الانتقاليه التي تولت السلطه بعد
اسقاط البشير احيت اعمال السودانيين في
تحسن احوالهم اذ رفعت واشنطن بلادهم من
قائمه الدول الراعيه للارهاب وعادت
المساعدات الاجنبيه التي ناهزت ملياري
دولار سنويا الا ان الدول المانحه قررت
تعليق مساعداتها للسودان بعد الاجراءات
التي اتخذها قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان في اكتوبر 2021
وشملت حل مجلس الوزراء والسياده
الانتقاليين مؤكده انها لن تستانف دعمها
للخرطوم ما لم تعد السلطه الى ايدي
المدنيين
الاقتصاد السوداني لم يشهد نموا منذ عام
2019 الا في عام 2021 فقد سجل نموا طفيفا
بنحو 0.5% لينكمش مجددا في عام 2022 صندوق
النقد توقع نمو اقتصاد السودان خلال العام
الجاري ب 2.5 الا ان الاحداث الاخيره قد
تعيد الاقتصاد الى مربع الانكماش ويحاصر
التضخم الاقتصاد منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
فخلال 2022 ارتفع التضخم الى اكثر من
154% وفي يناير الماضي بلغت تضخم السنوي
نحو 83% لكن هذه الارقام كانت قبل الازمه
الراهنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
ويعتمد السودان على الخارج لتغطيه معظم
احتياجاته من النفط والغذاء وفي ظل تدهور
قيمه عملته وارتفاع الاسعار عالميا سجل
السودان خلال 2022 اعلى عجل في ميزانه
التجاري منذ 2012 ويساوي الدولار الواحد
حاليا في المتوسط نحو 600 جنيه سوداني
مقابل متوسط بين 18 الى 47 جنيها للدولار
الواحد في 2018 كل هذه العوامل انعكست
تدهورا في مستويات المعيشه واستراجع
القدره الشرائيه وارتفاع التضخم وارتفاع
مستويات الديون الخارجيه وغياب
الاستثمارات الاجنبيه وبالطبع وفي حال
تفاقم الازمه الراهنه فان كافه المؤشرات
الاقتصاديه ستسير نحو الاسوا محمد زهير
العربيه
اذا ساعتنا الاخباريه التي تواكب تغطيه
الاحداث في السودان والجاليه هناك منذ
ثلاثه ايام الاشتباكات الجاريه بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني التغطيه الان
للزميل طالب كنعان اليك طالب تفضل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات